toutes ces petites mouches l'aquitain
bête oh là là où les mouches ou qu'ils
essayent de les manger il essaye de les
manger de doux fort de ses 800 kg et lan
boulonnais de 8 ans veille au grain sur
ces quatre autres camarades annabi
obélix anouk et princesses dans ce pré
d'arnaud ville aimante ce sont cinq
équidés poneys ou chevaux qui attendent
une famille pour la vie ils ont été
recueillis par l'association seconde vie
pour les équidés créé en 2009 ce sont
cinq bénévoles qui se relaient
quotidiennement auprès de ses
pensionnaires nos missions c'est
effectivement dans l'accueil d'équidés
et enfin de deux chevaux de poneys et
d'ânes voilà deux façons effectivement à
pouvoir envisager avec eux la recherche
de familles d'accueil pour une pré
retraite une retraite en fonction de
leur état deux autres équidés attendent
aussi leurs familles dans un second très
près de senneville et six sont en
hébergement chez des particuliers des
animaux qui ont chacun leur histoire
vient d'un élevage il a été acheté
effectivement pour des activités 1-2
plage à un an et demi il a eu la maladie
de lyme cap a été traitée tout de suite
et du coup il a une malformation assez
évidente c'est à dire qu'il a tout la
croupe arrière qui est complètement
avaler c'est à dire qu'il a pas de
groupe la négligence la sortie de centre
les séparations monde en a aussi qui
sortent de centres de centres équestres
et qui vont vers une pré retraite en
rien habille par exemple elle a fait
beaucoup de centres une excellente
ponette et sa propriétaire c'était la
monitrice
donc elle l'a pris pour la pré retraite
sauf que bon entre ses activités etc
elle avait mis au près le problème c'est
qu'à s'est bien rendu compte qu'elle
était placée assez disponible le prêt
est ouvert au public le mercredi et
samedi l'association propose plusieurs
activités notamment des balades
familiales objectif rendre l'équitation
plus accessible faites donc des petites
activités dont les balades ce
rendez-vous un débat là d'une demi-heure
une heure généralement ces balades
familiales à dakhla les parents viennent
avec les enfants on accueille voilà des
autistes et pas des personnes
polyhandicapées des personnes en
insertion au total ce sont plus de 80 et
qui d adopter en 13 ans l'association
est toujours en recherche de dons ou de
parrainage reconnu organismes d'intérêt
général 66 % de la somme est déductible
des impôts